let's begin with the strikes operation
iron sword that has now begun uh what
more can you tell us about the strikes
that have begun hitting
Gaza well the Israeli air strikes have
uh started in different areas of Gaza
but the most two significant strikes
were one in the on the uh Hospital
Indonesian Hospital a part of the
hospital was destroyed and one
Palestinian of the medical Crews working
in the hospital was killed in that
targeting while the other targeting is
at the 's Crossing or checkpoint in the
northern part of Gaza Strip a number of
injuries were taken to a shifa hospital
uh they were the the edas itself was
targeted uh people or local Witnesses in
the area said that the building
collapsed on a number of people in that
area so um a a number about dozen have
been taken to uh a shifa hospital from
that targeting while the targeting in
different areas we could just see uh
smoke balling in front of us from
different areas in Gaza as I speak now
and uh it it is going on um Yes
mine I want to ask you uh about these
reports of fighting ongoing at the eras
Crossing which is of course one of the
most important Crossings between uh the
Gaza Strip and and
Israel what more can you tell us about
what is happening there and also reports
that uh a prison the uh one of the
prisons has been taken over by the
Palestinian groups what do you
know well we've seen pictures for
Palestinian Fighters taking over uh the
Edis Crossing uh totally and a number of
Israeli soldiers killed uh uh the
picture of or the footage of the taking
over of the of that Aris Crossing and
the killing of the Israeli soldiers and
even in their uh in their uh uh hiding
places or in their uh shelters uh in the
around the Aris Crossing uh there were
also pictures for uh soldiers killed
there the Palestinian Fighters announced
that they have full control of the Eris
Crossing there were Al there was also
news by the Palestinian uh Fighters
saying that they have taken over
uh uh ashalon prison which is 45 minutes
away from Edis yet we do not have any
pictures or videos confirming that
saying by the Palestinian Fighters so
again uh we uh to see neither even
Israeli Media or Israeli uh uh Army has
confirmed anything or mentioned anything
about the uh uh ashalon prison it has
not denied that uh uh claim and it has
not even or has not uh confirmed that
claim yet so we're still waiting for uh
video or pictures to confirm that uh uh
that claim by Palestinian Fighters now
we're still seeing pictures we're still
seeing videos of more Israelis being
brought into the Gaza Strip just a very
short while ago there was a an Israeli
jip or vehicle military vehicle here in
the Gaza Strip circulating in the
streets it was taken over by Palestinian
fighters who were uh uh firing in the
air to celebrate the victory of taking
over this vehicle this is the third
Israeli vehicle to be entering the Gaza
Strip we're still seeing a lot a number
of uh uh pictures and videos for the
Israelis who have who have been captured
as hostages into Gaza the latest was for
a a full Israeli family that has been
brought uh the the the wife the kids and
even uh an old lady there uh they say a
whole family has been recently captured
and brought oh you that's that's pretty
extraordinary isn't it I mean tell us
tell us how unprecedented it is to to
have something like this happen for the
Palestinian groups to be able to bring
them bring an entire Israeli family into
into the Gaza Strip and capture them
well these pictures these actions uh
this attack all this is a historic uh uh
is a these are all historic scenes in
the history of the confrontations or the
conflict between Palestinians and
Israelis it has not happened one time in
the entire uh back history of the
Israeli Palestinian conflict that
Palestinians were able to capture this
amount of uh or number of Israelis and
bring them uh to Gaza until until now
Israeli media has spoken about over 35
Israelis not the exact number they say
but they say at least 35 Israelis uh
from soldiers and uh civilians were
captured as hostages into Gaza but we're
still seeing and and even after that
announcement we're still seeing more
Israelis being captured and brought into
Gaza so this whole attack since it
started uh this whole War uh the the the
launching of the rockets in this ex
excessive amount uh the infiltrating
into the B into the Israeli towns the
confrontations of the borders the armed
confrontations the taking over Israeli
sites and locations and tanks burning
them bringing in back Israeli military
vehicles into the strip these are scenes
that are unprecedented they are
extraordinary they have never happened
before in the history of the conflict
between Israelis and Palestinians okay
for now thank you y s there on uh
joining us from Gaza I want to bring in
our correspondent Ali Hashim now and
pick up on what we're hearing and seeing
in some of those pictures an entire
Israeli family being brought into the
Gaza Street
by these uh
Palestinians what do you think is going
on here why are they taking them these
Israelis
hostage well um as we heard earlier from
the commander of hamas's uh